what I want to do in this video is
answer an age-old question or at least
an interesting question to me and the
question is let's say I have a Ledge
here I have a ledge or cliff or maybe
this is a building of some kind and
let's say it has height H so let's say
it has a height of H right over here and
what I'm curious about is if I were to
either let's say that this is me over
here so this is me if I were to either
jump myself and that's not recommended
for very large H's or if I were to throw
something maybe a rock off of this ledge
how fast would that either myself or
would that rock be going when it gets
right before it hits right before it
hits the ground and like all of the
other videos were doing on projectile
motion right now we're going to ignore
air resistance then for small HS and for
small velocities that's actually
reasonable or if the object is very
aerodynamic and has and it's kind of
dense then the air resistance will not
matter less if it's me kind of
belly-flopping from a high altitude then
the air resistance will start to matter
a lot but for the sake of simplicity
we're going to assume we're going to
assume no air or we're not going to take
into effect the the effects of air
resistance or we could assume that we're
doing this on on an earth-like planet
that has no atmosphere however you want
to do it so let's just think about the
problem and just so you know some of you
might think that's that's not realistic
but this so actually would be realistic
for a small H if you were to jump off of
a off of the roof of a one-story
building air resistance will not be a
major component in determining your
speed if it was to be a much larger
building than all of a sudden matters
and I don't recommend you do any of
these things those are all very
dangerous things much better to do it
with a rock so that's actually the
example we're going to be considering so
let's just think about this a little bit
we want to figure out we want to figure
out so at the top of right when the
thing gets dropped right when the rock
gets dropped you have an initial
velocity you have an initial velocity of
zero and once again we're going to use
the convention here that positive
velocity means upwards negative or a
positive vector means up
negative vector means down so we're
going to have an initial velocity over
here of zero and then at the bottom at
the bottom we're going to have some
final velocity we're going to have some
final velocity some final we're going to
have some final velocity here that is
going to be a negative number
so it's going to have some negative
value over here so this is going to be
negative this is going to be a negative
number right over there and we know that
the acceleration of gravity for an
object of on freefall an object in
freefall near the surface of the earth
we know and we're going to assume that
it's constant so our constant
acceleration is going to be negative 9.8
meters per second squared so what we're
going to do is give it an H and given
that their initial velocity is zero and
then our acceleration is negative 9.8
meters per squared we want to figure out
what our final velocity is going to be
right before we hit the ground we're
going to assume that this is this H is
given in meters right over here and
we'll get an answer in meters per second
for that final velocity so let's see how
we can figure it out so we know we know
some basic things and the whole point of
these is to really show you that you can
always derive these more interesting
questions from very basic things that we
know so we know that displacement is
equal to displacement is equal to
average velocity average velocity times
change in time times change in time and
we know that average velocity average
velocity if we assume acceleration is
constant which we are doing average
velocity is the final velocity plus the
initial velocity plus the initial
velocity over to and that our change in
time our time or our the amount of
elapsed time that goes by this is our
change in velocity so elapsed time is
the same thing I'll write it over here
is our change in velocity divided by
divided by our acceleration and just to
make sure you understand this it just
come straight from the idea that
acceleration or let me write
that change in velocity change in
velocity is just acceleration times time
or I should say acceleration times
change times change in time so if you
divide both sides of these this equation
by acceleration you get this right over
here so that is what our displacement
remember I want an expression for
displacement in terms of the things we
know and the one thing that we want to
find out well for this example right
over here for this example right over
here we know a couple of things well
actually let me let me take it step by
step we know that our initial velocity
is zero our initial velocity is zero so
this first expression for the example
we're doing the average velocity is
going to be our final velocity our final
velocity divided by two since our
initial velocity is zero our change in
velocity change in velocity is the same
thing change in velocity is the same
thing as final velocity minus initial
velocity minus initial velocity and once
again we know that the initial velocity
is zero here so our change in velocity
is the same thing as our final velocity
so once again this will be times instead
of writing change in velocity here we
can just write our final velocity
because we're starting at zero initial
velocity is zero so times our final
velocity divided by our acceleration
divided by our acceleration final
velocity same thing is change in the
velocity because the initial velocity
was zero and all of this is going to be
all of this is going to be our
displacement and now it looks like we
have things in we have everything
written in things we know so if we
multiply both sides of this expression
or both sides of this equation by two by
two times our acceleration by two times
our acceleration on that side and we
multiply the left-hand side by do the
same colors two times our acceleration
two times our acceleration on the left
hand side we get two times our
acceleration times times our
displacement times our displacement is
going to be equal to on the right hand
side the two cancels out with the two
the acceleration cancels acceleration
it will be equal to the velocity our
final velocity squared it will be equal
to our final velocity our final velocity
squared final velocity times final
velocity and so we can just solve or for
final velocity here so we know what our
we know our acceleration is nine point
is negative 9.8 meters per second
squared
so let me write this over here so this
is negative 9.8 so we have 2 times
negative 9.8 so I can just let me just
multiply that out so that's negative
nineteen point six meters per second
squared times meters per second squared
and then our what's our displacement
going to be what's the displacement over
the course of dropping this rock off of
this ledge or off of this roof so you
might be tempted to say that our
displacement is H but remember these are
vector quantities so you want to make
sure you get the direction right from
where the rock started to where it ends
what's it doing it's going to go it's
going to go a distance of H but it's
going to go a distance of H downwards
and our convention is down is negative
so in this example our displacement our
displacement from when it leaves your
hand to when it hits the ground the
displacement is he going to be equal to
negative H it's going to travel a
distance of H but it's going to travel
that distance downwards and that's why
this vector notion is very important
here in our convention is very important
here so our displacement over here is
going to be it's going to be negative H
and negative H meters negative H meters
so this is this is the variable and this
is the shorthand for meters so when you
multiply these two things out lucky for
us these negatives cancel out and you
get nineteen point six nineteen point
six H nineteen point six H meter squared
per second squared meter squared per
second squared is equal to our final
velocity squared is equal to our final
velocity squared and notice when you
square something you lose the sign
information if our final velocity was
positive you square it you still get a
positive value if it was negative and
you square it you still get a
value but remember this example we're
going to be moving downwards so we want
the negative version of this so to
really figure out our final velocity we
take the essentially the negative square
root of both sides of this equation
because if you just do so if we were to
take the square root of both sides of
this so you take the square root of that
side you take the square root of that
side you will get and I'll flip them
around
you'll get your the velocity is equal to
your final velocity we could say is
equal to the square root of nineteen
point six H and if you can even take the
square root of the meter squared per
second squared
treat them treat them almost like
variables even though their units and
then outside of the radical sign you
will get a meters meters per second and
the thing I want to be careful here is
if we just take the principal root here
the principal root here is the positive
square root but we know that our
velocity is going to be downwards here
because that is our convention so we
want to have we want to make sure we get
the negative square root so let's try it
out with some numbers we've essentially
solved what we set out to solve at the
beginning of this video how fast would
we be falling as a function of the
height but let's try it out with some
things let's say that the height is I
don't know let's say the height is let's
say the height is five meters five
meters which would be probably jumping
off of a or throwing a rock off of a
one-story maybe a commercial one-story
building it's about that's about five
meters would be about fifteen feet
so yeah but by the roof of a commercial
building give or take and so let's turn
it on and so what do we get if we put
five meters in here we get nineteen
point six nineteen point six times five
times five gives us 98 so almost 100
almost 100 and then we want to take the
square root of that it's going to be
almost ten so the square root of 98 it
gives us nine point roughly nine point
nine and we want the negative square
root of that so in that situation when
the height is five meters so if you jump
off of a one-story commercial building
you're going right at the bottom or if
you throw a rock right at the bottom
right before hits the ground it will
have a velocity it will have
a velocity of negative nine point nine
meters per second so negative nine point
nine meters per second I'll leave it up
to you as an exercise to figure out how
fast this is in either km/h or miles per
hour and you'll see it's pretty fast
it's like you know it's not something
you'd want to do and this is just off of
a one-story building but you can really
figure this out you can use this for
really any height as long as we're
reasonably close to the surface of the
earth and you ignore the effects of air
resistance at really high Heights
especially if the object is not that
aerodynamic then air resistance will
start to matter a lot